it exists because of this
and this you shot four bullets into him
sir
he was just getting his license straight
in registration sir
which could rise to this
black lives matter is a hashtag a
rallying cry a movement
and it lies directly at the intersection
of race relations and deadly force
in america so here's the situation the
us government doesn't keep an official
count of shootings by law enforcement
but an ongoing washington post tally
identified 990 fatal shootings
by law enforcement in 2015. of the 93
unarmed civilians killed by police in
these cases more than
40 percent were black despite the fact
that black people make up 13
of the nation's population in 1992
when los angeles police officers were
acquitted over the beating of black cab
driver rodney king
there was anger there were riots but
there was no movement
today the difference is social media but
how did this movement
start in 2012 trayvon martin was gunned
down by george zimmerman
who wasn't a cop but a neighborhood
watch volunteer who claimed he shot
martin in self-defense
after zimmerman's acquittal in 2013 the
phrase black lives matter debuted as a
hashtag on twitter
and at signs on protest rallies around
the nation it re-emerged in a big way
a year later when michael brown was shot
by ferguson police officer darren wilson
and a protest freedom ride to ferguson
took place under the black lives matter
banner
more than 500 people from 18 cities
attended and in august of 2014
the black lives matter was used more
than 52
000 times now here's the argument
especially following the shootings of
police officers during a protest march
in dallas
the black lives matter movement is
spilling over to being an election issue
although not a clear-cut one while
hillary clinton is staunchly in favor of
the black lives matter movement
she hasn't impressed the movement's
leaders protesters disrupted a clinton
speech at a private fundraiser
as well as a speech by her husband
former president bill clinton
i love protesters
except when they won't let you answer on
the other side
donald trump isn't favored much either
you're gonna hear it
all lives matter trump has been critical
of the black lives matter protesters
and has said police are quote the most
mistreated people in this country